just a disclaimer I will post the link
on the meetup page meanwhile Maria hi
that's me
sorry I did not I did not see your
message before and also less less
kissing la casa no cactus sorry I
couldn't see your email before yeah some
other people in the US did not get the
link that's pretty standard I've been
able to go to some groups or in Europe
now but the link doesn't show up so
thanks for posting yeah you need to
adjust your username mister username
it's actually my work laptop I have like
four laptops lying around now and I have
to kind of see which one is working for
the zoo my face yeah the Internet is
quite stable and it's working so yeah
and and Maria before you you might have
heard about Peter Pittock right yes he
was a very good friend of mine okay so
is it true that I mean so he's confirmed
as missing or oh yes oh yeah almost and
obviously you can takea someone did it I
guess all his friends and family are
obviously not hoping anymore no okay
yeah tragedy okay sorry
and just to be ready when do we start we
can slowly start I don't know yeah I
don't think we need to be as punctual as
ever you want to wait until 50 people
zoom how many people did RSVP on the
meter
I like hundred more than 100 so we have
yeah I think we're complete like I think
this is everyone who is going to join so
your guess is that we have about 3035
percent show up that no I think a lot of
people who can handle votes I mean a lot
of people can also watch it on YouTube
stream so you know yeah people are
already watching okay yeah
let's start
sure I mean if we do that later on later
people will come even later and data we
have we also have time because we just
thought at the YouTube stream as I would
like as it it's kind of a segue to the
talk before we start Maria could you
tell us about your background before we
dive into your talk so I studied
actually or originally political science
in Berlin at their people and decided
that I always wanted to be a physicist
then started studying physics at the
Technical University of Berlin then I
did that for four or five years in
parallel which was crazy because it's
exactly half an hour between the
universities by bicycle you know you
just like make the next lecture and then
kind of month path took me to South
Africa where did a bit of political
science been a bit of physics there did
PhD in quantum computing quantum machine
learning this field was just emerging in
that time and now I'm doing this for
like the last seven years and it's now a
juicy nice big research discipline as
part of quantum illusion so you're an
academic totally academic very
theoretical when I say I do hands-on
presentations it's probably the most
theoretical you ever hear okay cool
then I guess I will meet everybody and
then you can share your slides I can
start the recording and then we can
start just it's working yes actually
shipped so interrupt me if they have
questions maybe we can just read them
all sure I will mute all you will be
able to unmute yourself
oh I guess you can Alan okay oh yes you
can
good then start the recording cool
thanks so much
hi everyone good evening I don't know
who you are but I assume that you guys
are all program enthusiasts Python
enthusiasts data scientists people who
have done or have gotten their fingers
dirty a little bit in machine learning
and what I want to talk about is some of
the topic of basically my research for
the last seven years as I just said
which is quantum machine learning and I
know this won't be easy because it's
obviously like we have to like put quite
a basis on quantum computing because
before you can even understand what's
the scope of quantum computers and
machinery and so so on and so forth so I
will basically focus on one particular
angle which is very software heavy at
the moment and the basic idea before I
even start is actually quite simple it's
the idea of taking a quantum computer
and using it as a new network you tune
instead of weights you tune physical
parameters in your quantum circuit on
your quantum computation and you
interpret the result of measurements
basically as predictions and then we
start asking in the last year a couple
of years like what function classes does
that give give rise to can we say
something about generalization how can
we train these models and a whole
ecosystem has been built around this in
terms of software so this is already the
whole message of the talk if it gets
that crazy at some stage don't expect
anything about Schrodinger's cat or
something like that I know when people
see quantum they're always like a bit
shocked if you don't start with all the
magic of Heisenberg and metaphysics and
stuff this is very like hands-on quantum
computers just implemented in algebra
this is something you can also like
program in a simulator and you know what
I know what was toasting machine them
just as a bit of a just to set the stage
basically so quantum machine learning is
a term you know you hear it more and
more since maybe the last five or six
years it's used in different sectors and
there's a very nice like graphic you can
to show like what the different types
are and where we are actually talking
what we are talking about here so
quantum computing is just basically a
different paradigm of computation that
uses different physics so to speak might
push the boundaries of what's possible
in terms of computation however this is
very very hard to characterize so if you
look into quantum computing research
it's very hard to put your finger
actually on something I mean like
newspaper articles always claims
interference it's in tandem and do its
parallelism but if you ask any quantum
computing researcher they give you a
very different answer what's the
resource that actually makes quantum
computers may be interesting so from for
all the metals and purposes for us it's
just a different paradigm computing and
classical computing and machine learning
as you all know is a way of analyzing
very specific data if we don't have
really an uncertain idea how like a
model for the state it could like like
look at so agnostic data science and now
there are different ways you can
actually combine quantum computing and
machine learning and their fields like
we use so you can distinguish them by
the type of data use and the type of
algorithm is this classic or quantum
there's lots of really cool research and
all those sectors that you can draw from
those what we are looking at is this one
here you give me just your classical
machine learning problem that you always
work on I have a quantum computer what
can I do that's the question and in some
sense this is interesting because even
if you don't think that quantum
computers are these crazy machines that
can actually do a lot of things you can
use them more as you know hardware
accelerators almost so what happens if
the whole idea of a ion machine knowing
becomes or gets a different hardware
type and they're actually two different
types of hardware that we talked about
one that you see more and more used like
and you know like developed in the labs
of Google IBM Intel academic labs are
these quantum devices they are you must
imagine them as little chips that are
the first prototype of quantum computers
they are small they're noisy they don't
work very well often they're often
accessible through the cloud so they're
very cool cloud interfaces so like
actually people can play with them and
then there's always this like Julia's
big idea of one day will they have the
real quantum computer and what makes
this real is that it's bigger but
especially that it's error corrected so
you actually don't have these errors or
noise in the computations and in your
result but you will have actually like
deterministic result out of a computer
and this divided between the hardware is
actually very much reflected also if
you're interested in this research of
quantum computing and this reflects back
to quantum machine learning there's this
good or quantum computing where people
do things like in the last 30 years
where this has to be developed as theory
and then there's kind of almost the you
know the folks that do the near-term
stuff and it's a very different way of
how to think about machine learning in
in both two camps and I'm talking about
the near-term idea so we've got these
little devices they're noisy what can we
do with us
software Susan since most of you are
actually programmers or interested in
programming software is like really
central to this it's central to educate
people it's central to prototype and and
simulate devices before you even have
them so we can just like write software
packages where you can simulate quantum
computations it's also important as an
interface and especially in graphical
interfaces to quantum computers and what
I show here is like you might have seen
it before
IBM items quantum experience why this
one so almost every company by now has
some kind of interface a nice graphical
playground but IBM were really the first
ones to push this this big vision of you
know you can compose your quantum
computation you can send it via the
cloud to like New York and do all sorts
of shenanigans and what I'll be talking
about so I always have code examples and
they are written mostly if they're not
written in fact watch in in penny lane
Penny Lane is a software library that
I'm you know part of developing and have
been like since a couple of years and
the idea of Penny Lane is not so much to
be a software for quantum computers like
the others but its first and foremost in
the last year's it was developed to be
there for quantum machine learning so is
exactly the topic that we have and I'll
get back to how it works like just now
okay in terms of agenda who knows I
don't have a lot of time and I know you
know about machine learning I just want
to work out one or two things and maybe
in a slightly different way of how you
usually get an introduction like
commercial ways of thinking about
machine learning more practical ways
and then the moist time I want to spend
on the quantum computing basics and I
know this talk is not about quantum
computing but I want to do it in a way
so they if we even stop after the
section here because I ran out of time
you would already know quite a lot about
how quantum machine learning could be
done and what you know bells and
whistles you have to not consider there
but if I've got time I would like to
also look into like now questions of you
know how we can train these quantum
computers how they connected neural
networks what they actually do okay
you see on the left side here always the
mathematical notation but if you don't
like formalisms then just up on the
right side we've got as most of you know
like three ingredients as for machine
learning and this is like following
statistical learning theory thinking
about this part that is called
supervised learning so it's just maybe a
little part of machine learning so to
speak so you've got data in this case
like one dimension inputs one
dimensional outputs lift you have a
regression problem right you've got a
classification problem and this data is
produced by some law and in some sense
the idea of machine learning is to make
an answer for this law that produces
outputs from inputs because I always
want to like show a bit of code
so in torch you would for example now
write down data in like this torch
tensor data structure so for example
you've got inputs and outputs three
pairs of data a second ingredient is a
model family and this is actually
already enough to understand what I want
to do with quantum machine learning
later so just to be like sure that
meditation is clear here you make an
answers for this like you know a
relationship between X and one for
example you can say like my model family
that I use is a linear model and of
course usually not in or machinery
models as you know parameters that I can
tune for example in a linear model that
would be the y-intercept although the
inclination of your model and the model
takes X and kind of the parameters and
produces Y so this is important we have
a whole model family that we select so
your model could be you know patches
something as simple as you know this
linear model here it doesn't even ever
want is it you know the third ingredient
is a loss and the loss just tells you
like you know what's the error you make
so between your real data and like the
prediction of your model and now you
know
which is like comparing you give her two
data points that compares them with mean
square error but now here's the crucial
point so what is machine learning and I
actually like only recently thought
about it that you can actually formalize
it in this very nice way done in
statistical learning theory you try to
minimize the average loss of a model so
for example this here is the you know
the inclination of your of your line in
this two-dimensional space I was showing
earlier you try to find the inclination
of the parameter or the model so to
speak that minimizes this average loss
over all data is you could see all data
in this class for example if you look at
images or images that you could see
obviously you can compute this because
you can never like kind of do this
averaging process over all data you
could see so what you've got just kind
of a small data set and you've got a
different like called loss or cost
function or average loss you would call
it empirical risk in a theory
um so and just to say there's like lots
and lots in machine learning that you do
for example regularization which
includes like early stopping dropout all
sorts of tricks about cross-validation
all those tricks that are built around
machine learning in for examples I could
learn other libraries basically just
have the purpose of of like bridging the
problem that you have only a loss
function that you can minimize that's
based on the data sample so the small
set of data samples that you see that it
doesn't really reflect the original loss
function so just like to explain those
quickly if for example you've got images
and put images of cats but they were all
that taken on a sunny day then your
green function which is kind of the loss
function of your data sample that you
got given so this very biased data might
actually say the model is the best which
means the loss is the lowest the model
is the best you know here where you
actually like learn to see like Oh a
sunny day as a cat picture and if
there's no sunny day it's not a cat
picture but this is like a typical case
of overfitting and what you're trying to
basically do is find you know minimize
this loss function on on the data you
have on your empirical light data
samples but as a proxy to actually
minimize a loss function that you don't
have access to why I'm saying this so
this is not so crucial for the rest of
the talk so I'm saying this is um if you
think Santa
perfectly about how quantum computing
can help machine learning lots of people
think about you know how can it just
speed up algorithms or how can it's just
you know like kind of come in as as a
little accelerator somewhere but I'm
personally driven by this question of
how can quantum resources and quantum
computer like increase our
generalization capacity so how can we
make sure it finds not those solutions
that are overfitting and very bad but it
finds like really nice solution there
generalize well so this is the
overarching question that we're trying
to answer in quantum machine learning
and I think we haven't even started to
formulate the tools for this yet so
we'll really at the beginning okay
here's a full code example for pi torch
obviously most of you will know how it
works I just want to like highlight it
because I will show you
please the same example only
whatamachine running out so you've got
the lost function that I spoke about you
have a function that's the average loss
that kind of depends on the loss
function for each data point here and I
define an initial variable like five for
example you define our optimizer and
then your stepwise adapt the optimizer
and what's important here is like this
all judo with a backward and and what's
happening in those steps as most of you
know is great in based optimization so
most of machine learning relies on
gradient based optimization so you have
some information on where to go down in
your energy landscape so this is
important for just now okay cool perfect
I never like switch on my time oh and
with quantum computing so not
Schrodinger cats and not crazy magic
that let's look into quantum computing
from a very very pragmatic angle so if
you were to program a simulator how
would you have to do it and I use this
picture notation all the time you won't
see any cats or bras if you know except
from those ones here that for me just
like show that there's a qubit setting
so to speak
so what is this you have a system
consisting of n quantum bits and these
quantum bits you can just imagine as
being systems that
[Music]
we're losing you one of two stages
sorry thanks for telling me usually
after five seconds it comes back is
having better so they are the article
they just so it's not not the reason
that I'm in South Africa that my
internet is so bad the entire city has
fiber only our street is excluded so far
which really sucks please tell me again
okay cool so you've got these n spin
systems so to speak and these are the
ones the basis of your computation these
are the physical systems your computer
on now here's the crux is the whole
point of what I'm trying to make the
mathematical description of the system
doesn't work in an n-dimensional space
so you don't have n numbers to describe
this thing but you describe the system
by a vector on area of 2 to the N
numbers just as a bit of a background
why the idea of how do you interpret
those numbers is every entry corresponds
to one possible observation I could make
so for example the observation
everything is in state 0 or the
observation 1 spin is in state 1 the
rest is in 0 so every bit string
basically has a probability I actually
do a question oh yes if you don't mind
if we could serve express this this
physical basis of your observations in
terms of these machine learning terms
could we identify them as features of
some type of object that we're trying to
describe in n dimensions
I mean I think this already contains the
grain of the main message am I'm trying
to make oh I'm just like reinterpreting
what you're asking in this way but so
let me answer this two ways so in some
way what what we will afterwards do is
we will encode data in these qubits and
if we encode data like for example input
X and these qubits what we actually
effectively do we encode it in this
so we encode it into a tree to the
n-dimensional vector and if you do
machine on you know merely there's a
feature map we map something into a high
dimensional space so this is what you're
asking then your absolute genius to
quantum machine learning like four five
years to figure this out so just to
finish this quickly so this vector that
describes basically these measurement
result probabilities you have to read it
as follows you have to think of it as a
bookkeeping vector that keeps track of
some information that we can turn into
probabilities onto your distribution so
think of it as a we're distribution this
vector how you read is that if you take
the absolute square of these values here
and they are complex values why is a
long discussion it's just a very elegant
way of formulating quantum theory
basically if you take the absolute
square values you get the probability of
the event to happen basically at the
beginning of all quantum algorithms we
say like whole systems on zero what does
that mean
the first entry which is the probability
by convention actually that everything
is in zero is one every other
probability is zero so you've got just
like by convention this like you know
real one and you could also just have I
here by the way but yeah so this is the
idea so in short quantum systems all
quantum systems you can think of are
always described by okay let's see at
least like that dimensional discrete
ones are described by a vector of
complex values and usually this is
exponentially large so this vector is
intractable for anything you know if n
is larger than fifteen you already can't
really simulated on any computer on a
classical computer now I promised that I
will show you a penny lane code so and I
hope this really like brings the message
home a bit but let me just quickly just
describe what happens it so you import
the pin link package since this is or
the idea how lots of quantum
computations are implemented is the
following you define a circuit and then
you define a device and then you tie the
device and the circuit together and then
you run basically this like circuit on
the device so peneleus looks like this
the device you can specify the string
you have a lot of different devices that
you specify I show you just now and the
number of these subsystems so small
and as we call it wise so here I've got
two cubits so you've got a state of you
know your space your larger space in
which your calculators four-dimensional
to to the truth and now here's this like
decorator that ties the device to a
function which we call a quantum
functions a very specific function that
has jewelry written in a very specific
way to implement what you want to join
your quantum computer and at the moment
we don't do anything except from
returning probabilities so this is you
can do this like is implemented by just
just computing basically the absolute
squared values of your vectors if you
write a real Hardware you have to sample
to get an estimate of problems it's just
like and if we run the circuit you get
basically this probability distribution
over the events but if you look into the
circuit and you ask like what is the
state so what is actually this thing
here which we always do bookkeeping off
in simulators you see exactly these are
complex values your phone on but yeah so
this is exactly the specter that are
shown here basically and now quantum
simulators work just by keeping always
track of what happens to this vector
here internally atoms thing kind of like
computing probabilities and lots of
things out of this now we just like need
a couple of ingredients is to build
quantum algorithms hmm a quantum
algorithm can always be described by you
know like in the picture here we
describe it by this block that acts on
on these like subsystems it just means I
do some physical observer operations
some manipulation or shine laser light
turn some knobs whatever I do but it
manipulates those in qubits or these end
systems here in am a really large
dimensional space what happens this I
have a linear so called unitary
transformation of this vector
was it unitary just because I need to
make sure that these probabilities still
some add up to one so I can now
transform this vector here up here I
just show like kind of a visualization
of this this vector here and it just
turns this vector on a sphere so to
speak so afterwards I just get like some
other vector you know again code here
are coded up some some you this is a
unitary matrix so since all the
conditions we need and here my
my circuit now applies this unit area so
to speak and you see that my probability
distribution changed and also my
internal statement bookkeeping state
that produces the probability
distribution change so this is the state
here in the simulator is nothing that in
real life is really there it's just our
description of the system basically and
now you can run the quantum computer in
two modes you can measure which just
means you draw samples for example you
ask the computer you know what stage are
these qubits in so exactly like in coins
you know years for them and then you
look and you see like what state are the
which ones I've flipped up and which are
down so you get a whole number of
samples from this distribution here and
so in penny lane for example you can
just like change the output type from
probabilities to sample here and then
you get don't worry about like why this
power is if this is like quantum you
know specific quantum terms of
describing your measurement but you can
get samples out of your quantum computer
the state is still kind of the same as
before but now what you get out of the
quantum computer are minus ones in ones
which represent zeros and ones out of
traditional reasons but now it's
important so if you know a sample you
could use your quantum computer if you
use it as a machine any model as a
generative machine any model but if you
want to do something like a
deterministic machine running water like
something like in your net where you may
get a deterministic result it's always
the same however often you run it you
don't want the sampler so what you do
and this is very natural for quantum
theory you measure an average so instead
of getting like zero sometimes the one
you actually get a value like for
example 0.6 which means 60% of the cases
you cubed was in this stage and 40% in
the other stage and I know this looks
like a big monster if you don't do maths
a lot but in this really large space of
your description what happens is
something called a quadratic form so you
take this like a matrix vector
multiplication you compute a royal
vector complex conjugate vector of it
and then you sandwich basically a big
measurement matrix that describes your
measurement in the middle so it's not so
important what these things are but the
only point I want to make here to
describe a quantum computation you just
have to do linear algebra so this is a
bit nonlinear because there's a
quadratic form but you know what I mean
it's matrix vector multiplication so to
speak
so this is called the expectation value
it's a different type of measurement so
to speak and you can just change the
sample into X vowel and you get like you
know not samples but you not get like
something else like deterministic
outcomes this is the expectations of the
second qubit could be any values just an
example
okay now okay one last ingredient
quantum circuits are not like a big
unitary blob like a big matrix that I
apply but in the lab in physics you do
something very local here just one qubit
or one spin and then maybe two so what
happens in your mathematical
representation you have not one big
matrix but you have actually a lot of
matrix multiplications and if I don't
get to this is already interesting
because a matrix multiplication is kind
of a bit like a linear neural network
you can imagine so you have modular kind
of layers almost at your plan okay I
have no clue what I did earlier I
replaced the unit area now by like and
these gates have different names and
their standards which gates are
interesting and stuff like that so this
is just like a decomposed circuits
twenty random one are you now to
ingrediences after which I can already
like basically say how these models are
now used for machine learning first is
an insight that you know if you're
opening your quantum computing textbook
you won't see this so often but actually
these these so-called gates these
manipulations of qubits are actually
just physical things and very often you
have got a physical knob that you tune
like a parameter for example the
strength of an electromagnetic field
there's something you can tune in your
lab which means that these gates depend
on parameters so that's nice right like
in your network like weights and we know
since many years how to tune those
parameters again let me go quickly to
the codes though there are gates very
famous are powered so called County
rotations they're called rxry as it so
he showed one of those gates that takes
actually a parameter so in the circuit
and now the result depends on what the
slack parameter is of this plane so so
this parameter actually defines now not
a single circuit which is a single
computation but it defines a family of
models immediately so you in the space
of machinery and the last ingredient
lists are related to that
so if Ellie asks can we do machine
learning in these quantum simulators
then and what would be the performance
performance difference it's compared to
traditional CPU GPU models that we have
great ask me again in five minutes I
think I should be ready and then maybe
it's a bit ok um actually might not go
to the end anyways um so the last but
you're thinking if if you interpret this
thing as a model if the motor I haven't
spoken about data at all but obviously
quantum circuits and quantum
computations have to depend on inputs
even Shor's algorithm from the 90s all
of those depend on inputs so implicitly
the first step that you don't know on a
quantum computer is always like what
I'll call the encoding step so you take
a data sum and somehow you have to get
it into the quantum state and now here's
what we're talking about here like what
Michelle said is that if you interpret
this also as one of these matrix vector
multiplications you do it right at the
start but now this matrix depends on X
what happens is that finally your data
vector depends on X as well so what do
you do you invent data into very high
dimensional spaces and this is
immediately something you should know
from support vector machines from kernel
theory from-from a lot of ideas in
machine learning maybe not in your
network so much but like that were very
popular in the 90s let me just see what
I've done here or oh yeah okay so this
is just the circuit was like a parameter
and now I've got you know also a data
point here don't worry about why I use
this as a keyword argument for now this
has more historical reasons oh yeah um
but you see that what I did here
actually in terms of data encoding I can
do they structured data in codings but I
could also just throw my X into another
rotation gauge and then I have another
rotation about called in our Y rotation
for the parameter so basically I
associate physical parameters with data
and with trainable parameters in a very
similar fashion and I can train the
whole thing and people have done that in
quantum control all the time like since
since hundreds of you or 100 years at
least so yeah so this is now my
trainable model so in Penny Lane a full
example of optimizing a quantum circuit
so to speak at the moment
for some reason I didn't put data in
here looks actually very much like Patos
right like you know you define an
optimizer and then you have a step off
the optimizer and you can actually like
chain the quantum circuit so first of
all years the software simulators not
the usual ones so something like Penny
Lane that's geared for quantum machine
learning can train quantum circuits most
of the bigger frameworks if you heard of
kiss kid from IBM and stuff I think they
kind of slowly trying to get it into it
into there like frameworks but this
software has been really built on this
idea and just a very quick at that it's
built around is that you can really
quickly change your devices so what my
internet connection is unstable back
okay you can try cool I usually never
have problems with Animus the first
webinar that doesn't work as a but
anyways okay cool so you've got
different devices you can use you can
use for example IBM's devices Google's
devices or simulators so whenever
someone has software we can write a
plug-in to to Penny Lane and in the end
it's just a matter of changing this one
line and then you will tie the circuit
to a different device and run it
somewhere differently so pinyin is
completely agnostic on where something
runs okay now I don't have a lot of time
for quantum machine learning I just want
to give you one more ingredient that
hopefully answers a bit of the question
of can we train those those models
because I was kind of you know lying
about or there's one big hurdle
basically so why ideas we use quantum
computations as machine learning models
I think the first time this was
exploring these two papers and there's a
very nice overview here benedetti at all
and these ones are archive references so
if you type them in with archive you
should they are XIV you should actually
find the paper okay so this is the whole
set up we can train our models now
here's a problem if I want to train my
model I told you before that if we go to
high dimensions we need gradient
information and it's not necessarily
given that if I take you know the
derivative of this function that
was calculated by a quantum computer
with respect to a parameter that I
actually get another function that a
quantum computer can calculate so in
terms of a bigger picture if for example
my quantum model I couldn't now quantum
node is part of a bigger computation and
for example like a big in your network
where the layers done by a quantum
computer and I want to now back
propagate or differentiate through the
quantum computation in order to do a
gradient based optimization my big
problem is that I can run the quantum
algorithm but I don't know how to get
gradients out of it and this was a big
insight like a big building block that
almost enabled this whole our research
field that says the following I can get
a gradient out of a quantum device if I
just run the circuit twice but the
parameter with respect to which I want
to like get the partial derivative I
have to shift it once to the one side
and once to the other side now that
looks a bit like finite difference for
watches wiggle a bit to the left wiggle
a bit to the Latin tree right but it's
actually a macroscopic shift so the the
geometry of quantum physics really has
different rules about how to get
gradients out of out of devices so this
was a bit much we can just say we can
compute gradients on quantum devices so
we can make them part of machining
patterns and there's a whole ecosystem
now in your optimizers you know like
quantum nature agreed you know what can
we do with shots like there's a lot of
like work on this there's a bit of
concern because there has been a
theoretical results that our gradients
might vanish we have a vanishing
gradient problem in these quantities so
there's a lot of research that now like
you can play the whole games of kacica
machine learning in quantum machine
basically and I just want to show you a
kind of the full example and this one
here is a bit different because it uses
a penny Lincoln can interface with high
torch
tensorflow or numpy I showed you the
numpy version which is kind of like
looks almost like you just do native
Python programming but so this one is
the patriotic version so it was the
first example but as quantum computation
so it's exactly the same you define a
data you define a device you define a
quantum circuit here use not single
gates but templates like already higher
order compositions of quantum circuits
you have the loss function from before
the average loss and then I do exactly
the same that I did before in the top 40
example but now I'm training a quantum
computation since I don't get to any
lack of the rest you can ask me
questions about it I have a bit on
quantum your networks and stuff like
that but so just to summarize the big
idea now for a scientist is to
understand what models do these circuits
give rise to so do they like really like
look like an your network do they look
more like maybe a kernel method and
stuff like that lots of people want them
to look like new networks my personal
opinion is that you always have to bend
over backwards to implement the
nonlinearities and quantum physics so
the best nicest picture to have is that
we map data into these big high
dimensional spaces and then we do the
algebra with them so in business very
much like what the kernel method or
support vector machine does under
certain circumstances so there's a very
very interesting theory coming out of
that yes and now to answer this question
how well are they doing and here's a big
problem and I put it on like as one of
the questions here one of the big
problems is that in a machine learning
people or in machine learning contexts
what you do your benchmark a model to
see if it's doing well right who report
the test error and then you see like as
a jingle or not we can't do that because
our simulations are automatically
restricted by this like exploiting space
that we have to do the bookkeeping in so
we can only simulate like something like
you know maybe if I want to do it
quickly like 15 cubits if you do really
put all your efforts there maybe 50
cubits but then immediately it gets
impossible so we can't use simulators
but the real devices also they are small
they're noisy they're not working very
well so basically try to like think
about machine learning in a space well
we cannot have access to the models that
we're trying to like develop so what's
the answer here is probably like a lot
of theory building a lot of like sitting
back and maybe waiting a couple of years
where we like to try to understand like
things on paper first of all but there
lots of other good questions and I say
like they are different questions from I
get often this question like can quantum
algorithms learn [ __ ] are they faster
are there this and that we really don't
know yet and it's a very very high level
questions almost as big as the question
on neural networks
which near network is the best like you
can't you almost can't answer this
question I mean for no free lunch
reasons or something or whatever but
what I want to say is that quantum
machine is really at the beginning and
there are a lot of like smaller
questions we can ask that are really
really interesting and it's a bit about
like the domains that came our works on
is the idea can we scale things do this
like gradient vanishing gradient
problems can we circumvent them can we
find two special quantum optimization
strategies and there lot of like things
to work on this it's a whole ecosystem
of
of work to do to make these quantum
models you know it'd be part of machine
learning maybe one day that's all I have
to say I hope I didn't run or a good
time and I got a bit of an idea of
quantum machine learning yeah and I
don't know if we do questions now maybe
after the second I have a question
just asking maybe that the very obvious
the very very very obvious question
dissimulation the simulations are
obviously exponential based on the size
of your data but if you had the device
then it would work linearly on that
actual size so then in that case if you
implement machine learning model then it
would be exponentially faster or it
would take the logarithm of the time
that a normal model take is that the
correct statement I think you have to
repeat the last part sorry you got it
exactly right right like yeah so you've
got the data once you have it you have
good space you can actually near the
owners yes now the question is given the
hardware device if I have imagined that
I have a data set and it would work in
the order of of n3 on usual algorithms I
have what would be the computational
order now on that computed under contro
device so it's the question for example
in support vector machines
have to now if we map things into this
high-dimensional we still have like
algorithms that are quadratic in the
data is this for example what you're
asking their papers they can show you
that quantum computers can always act
linear in the data and you very easily
get quadratic speed ups from quantum
computers in terms of your hilbert space
you are logarithmic in the size of the
hilbert space so if this doesn't spin so
um
you're Tony right the only problem is
that data encoding will always force you
to kind of like the at least linear in
the data and lots of the first quantum
machine learning proposes always saying
we have exponential speed ups but this
is I mean between you and me this is
obviously a very very weird claims
because you even have to like know if
the data in the first place and there's
a lot of controversial debate and now
they have all bendy quantized and
there's a lot of like false impact so to
cut a long story short I think in terms
of speed ups which is not my personal
viewpoint that this is the most
important thing we can probably get
polynomial speed ups quite nicely out of
quantum computers I'm not focusing on
them these small devices they can't even
do most of the algorithms that give us
those feet up so yeah just think that
brings us the next question which I have
here which is how many parameters can we
train with the devices we have these
days with devices all the simulators
that's the question so in the devices if
you take IBM quantum experience maybe
have a chip that has 20 cubits
immediately if you if you apply
something like depends on the type of
gate but if you'd applied 20 or 30 gates
your output is very noisy so it's it's
not a question of parameter is a
question of gates here in simulators
depends on how the simulators program we
have simulators that are programmed all
intensive flow for example that I intend
differentiable and there you can train
very quickly like 200-300 parameters but
you see we're not on the scale of of
neural networks yet right next question
I have is when can we expect qml to be
implemented commercially
we wish to do sometimes like tell
ourselves but at the moment there's a
lot of help stuff happening in you know
industry and also with companies but
they're always like proof of principle
studies or investigations to just see
what's happening in the space but you
would always be better off having a
classical computer for probably the next
five or ten years at least okay then I
guess that all senses the next question
which is how long until people are using
quantum machine learning in practice if
people tell you in five to ten years
it's always like twenty or thirty years
plus we fell off the Gartner hype cycle
recently I don't know quantum marketing
is not there anymore so okay next one
one of the arguments that gets made for
quantum supremacy algorithms lecture is
that cube it's a little more truly
independent parallel sampling of
distribution than classical computing
how does that translate to control
machine learning if it does is that
better or stronger sampling could be
more useful than brute speed-up
possibilities so the notion that quantum
computers are parallel devices are much
better than classical computers because
of that is complete honestly is complete
[ __ ] or if you want to be very nice
it's a didactic lie we tell to the media
to say something easy about them why if
you think about classical probability
distributions classical probabilistic
models live in a space that's as big as
quantum spaces you know if you describe
in classical coins you've got to -
they're in probabilities so this
parallelism is in some sense just the
fact that that you work in probabilities
however there is something that's
interesting is that you can interfere
probabilities you can do different
things with them so there is something
happening but we do not really you know
one of the biggest quantum computing
gurus in the world once told me I was
trying to develop an algorithm where we
interfere things to optimize you know
machine learning model and you just said
don't even try to engineer the
interference you just can't do it it's
yeah it's too structured or it's just
not clear
nice um I have another question in this
one figure that you showed with the
input of your cats into this box that
would somehow consume the cats that like
your basically your data input then you
get some output so my question is I mean
each of these features each of these
data points each of these parts of this
entire data point that you feed it isn't
it just another function I mean it's how
do we even compare it to this classical
notion of a data point I mean what you
are showing us isn't a data point it's a
family of functions that you feed to the
system so I'm not I don't fully
understand how this even compares it
seems more like if you have classical
machine learning you have some type of
universal function approximator and here
you have some universal function l yeah
approximator is that is that true is
that correct or am i misunderstanding it
or something no I think you don't have
functions that you act on okay in a very
deep sense yes but I think not in the
first iteration what happens for example
if your data is let's say your your data
you can binarize it and your data input
let's say it's one dimension you can
binarize it as 1 0 0 0 then you can
encode it into qubits that's one
strategy out of many right see the first
qubit and leave the other ones or the
second one whichever like it is ok and
in some sense this is what happens to
your physical system what happens to
your description this in this like
hilbert space in this description in
bookkeeping what happens is that you
change basically the probability
distribution yes so the best way to I
think phrase it I don't know if any one
of you there's a very technical idea but
like this idea of kernel mean embeddings
so you map data to a probability
distribution that's the closest you get
to to describe what happens just that
this probability distribution is quantum
and or classical so you so think of a
Gaussian you know normally to
distribution they're just like the
parameters are associated with your data
so you would ever dat you feel in your
garden will be different you got some
distribution that's the idea
okay it's a lot to get your head around
but okay but eventually you try to not
work on functions but on the parameters
that span these function families right
yeah you're trained so this is how you
feed your data and then you did
something very similar with with your
parameters and you just afterwards
trained them okay thanks
it takes it takes quite a bit I think to
to wrap your head around it but yeah
feel somebody still moderating I think I
didn't okay
oh yeah well yeah okay I was moderating
the session mute cool so the now we're
done with the first one the recording is
finished we are live on YouTube steel -
thanks a lot Maria that was awesome and
I really really enjoyed that I didn't to
continue we I forgot a few things that
we usually say at the beginning I'll go
over them and then we'll have a little
bit of an interview and then we'll
continue with the second talk to to
review for the people who are new to to
these meetups this is a playdate a
meet-up clearly it's a part of toy data
is a part the educational branch of non
focus which is an NGO which focuses on
the poi data stack and it does a lot to
support the data stack software and to
support people who use that software
through my data for example we usually
have or different different chapters
that's what we call these different PI
data is like PI data Berlin PI data I'm
surrounded these chapters some of them
also have conferences every year or
every few years
we're not a lot of them were canceled
this year clearly and instead we are
going to have a PI data global event
which you can find information on the
global that pied-a-terre org is Matt T
on the call still it's multi mute he's
not please go there if you if you would
like to give a talk
CHP is open you can submit proposals
already and I think it's gonna be in
November and if I'm not mistaken the
idea is also to have talks in different
time zones and there are gonna be people
from all around the world so it will be
hopefully a really nice conference so
Matty is there would you like to tell us
a few words about the global conference
your mute oh oh you're alright no I'm on
mute because you muted me and I can't
yeah so hide at a global is happening as
Alan said in November that's gonna be a
virtual conference all the details on
how that's actually going to be
organized and run you can find on global
pilot org the CFP is currently open for
another couple of weeks until the 2nd of
August I think so we are looking for
speakers but we are also going to be
looking for people to help us review all
the submissions that we'll get we're
hoping to have hundreds and hundreds of
submissions and so we want to open the
review process to the community at large
there's I'm currently actually working
on putting all of that together so
there's a there's more information on
that to follow the best way to follow up
on that is to either follow my data on
Twitter or if you're a member of any one
of the PI data meetup organizations that
are then already mentioned you should
get a notification through that that
system as well I don't have anything
more
cool you can use oh you can meet
yourself that's right another thing that
I wanted to mention is our code of
conduct we follow known focuses code of
conduct you're supposed to be nice to
each other like obviously not nice stuff
sexist racist homophobic behaviors are
not okay you can always tell the COC
team you can talk to me or Noah no is
now on the call if something happens on
top of that we are also adding a few
clauses because of certain incidents
that we had it's it's not comfortable
conversation but we should have it this
is a professional Meetup
that means that people don't most people
especially women given empirical data
don't come here to have dates or to be
here and when you come to these meetups
either online or in person that
shouldn't be the assumption everything
should be kept completely professional
if you want to add them or interact with
them with each other on any digital
platform that should be kept very very
professional and it should ideally be
with people's explicit consent you can
for example if you add people on
LinkedIn sending a message saying that
it was nice to get to know you on the
Meetup wink is not a professional
message that doesn't mean that you can't
be friendly with each other or you can't
find friends it only means that
everything needs to be very consensual
you can ask is it okay if we connect and
on a platform like linkedin or zink
and more than that as long as
do you have people's consent it's none
of anybody's business and if you
encounter any of those instances if you
if you receive any of those messages and
you're not comfortable with them it is
not okay that you receive them and you
can very very clearly contact us and we
will take the actions as we do with the
other instances of this you see
violation don't-ee with that out of the
way we this meter we we also had the
idea of joining some of the chapters
since they are virtual we could also use
some of the benefits of having a virtual
meetup like having speakers who don't
live in Berlin but also joining some of
the chapters together and we started
this one with joining some of the
efforts of Plato Jetta in Saudi Arabia I
gave a talk a few a few weeks ago in in
there middle and in this meter we have
yes mean one of the co-organizers and I
believe we also have quite a few people
from that group as our audience and I
guess I can with that handing the mic to
tell and he will interview yes
you're just so you know we're still life
I'm not sure if you wanted to broadcast
us but are you okay I'm okay with that
I'm just saying that last time we didn't
broadcast it so yes we did yes you know
you okay if we broke up that on on
YouTube can get mean a new chapter or
should we ever in to do that yeah I I
need to do your also co-host hi everyone
so yeah the that is not okay that we
also change that okay great
so hi everyone so last time some of you
were there also we need like two short
interview with two organizers and we
will do that again this time so this
time I will like to interview yes me and
from PI data to die in Saudi Arabia and
also Misha an organizer from PI data
balance the goal here is just to show
who is behind the organization and maybe
give you some motivation of idea if you
want to help organize a meet-up and
that's also the great thing with the
online that you are mainly somewhere
else and you think that maybe you want
to create your own PI data chapter in
your own City so that's the that's the
goal of that and we are also welcoming
feedbacks if you want to actually think
that question you would like to ask so I
would like to start with this mean so
three year three question first can you
tell us if you know what you are working
on at the moment what are you doing yeah
yeah sure I first thank you for inviting
me to talk basically we are an image
online webinars as we know due to to
cover tonight in situation we arranged
one week of each month we did our first
kickoff webinar on June and I journal
didn't say he was one of the speakers
were Nick would not would be on in July
25 next week will with Kwanzaa and he
will give a talk about subscribing and
beautiful so also we believe that the
Twitter account has also impact on
people so we are working on our Twitter
account to be more informative
we share we also share tricks and tips
about rice and Julia and other
open-source tool yeah thank you very
much that's that's cool I think yeah
sharing also with social media is
interesting
can can you tell me how and why did you
become involved in the organization yeah
my team and I have the same passion
about data as well as foreign cheering
that's why we are enjoying being part to
fight data we are enjoying sharing our
experience their knowledge with each
other also we learn everything we every
day we learn something new from each
other I offered from our four speakers
beside that we support our society to
contribute any open-source software
that's why we found that why data is the
right place for us and what what can you
recommend to someone who wants to get
involved so I think that what you can
ask for indeed I could also be anywhere
in any of the chapter yeah sure I mean
the best thing you can do it for
yourself as being a part of a community
that you are in terrific and this will
reflect in your personality your way of
thinking
you will be more confident and also it
will help you to increase your
connection circle and we all know about
the benefit from that you will get
worship opportunities also you will send
people that can project or you can
contribute in a new project
sorry my voice is getting because my
entrance is unstable
I'm not thinking is that can you repeat
the two last sentence yeah sure sure I
was our saying that this will help you
to to find the people that can help you
on your current project or you can
contribute with others on a new project
so if you have a chance don't miss this
opportunity and fly and be and be a part
of a community like by day for example
yeah I think you'll find people they
have the same I'm just saying that they
will how you really try to people they
have the same interest as you okay so
thank you for doing it - very much I
mean what we call start with you my
pleasure
yeah and you have a meet-up coming soon
and we'll put the link someone want to
join there we go okay
Misha idea can you little top a high
grade can you can you tell me you know
what you are working on right now right
now I have a couple of projects one of
them is I investigate the emergence of
success in in the field of science
studies that's sort of my my day job
apart from that I'm working on this once
column module which is basically geared
towards analyzing and extracting
so-called work records
as some very specific format by the
Internet Archive for those of you who
know what it is it's basically a very
large NGO well it's not that large
actually and they try to collect and
scrape information off the web and store
it and archive it
what can you how and why do you become
involved so what the job were in the PI
data thing in the PI data in the PI data
well I think I my first idea was in
December 2000 no it couldn't be December
might have been January 2018 and I
basically wanted to get more involved in
in just data science because I wasn't
quite as happy with physics as maria's
for multiple reasons so I wanted to
switch a little bit and since usually
physics allows you to get a lot of
experience in programming or at least if
you're in theory it was a fairly easy
switch and I'd tried to find some
community that is sort of as close to my
interest as possible and putida ended up
being it yeah I I did edit simulation
KVL for one and I think like finding of
I mean helping a lot you know what you
need to know anything yeah exactly like
the talks are interesting plus you get
sort of your finger on on the pulse of
what's happening right now in the city
what's the not necessarily the state of
the art but what is a more well
professional and non-academic stance on
all of these developments that's what I
actually like that about pi data the
most that it wasn't as academic as I was
used to and I really enjoyed the like
of it like if we had meetups at solando
or I mean we there were so many
different meetup locations and so many
different hosts it was really
interesting just to hear their their
their business model that was also very
interesting for me as well hopefully we
can meet each other quite soon I hope so
too let's see also give me a date for
the moment and really quickly the last
one what would you recommend to someone
who wants to get involved if you want to
get involved in PI data just approach
people and be patient and I think the
consistency is the most important part I
think if you are if you need some
consistency or if you like consistency
or if you are consistent in your
behavior I think this is very it was
very useful
and it will help when you want to get
involved with PI data plus today's my
birthday so I'm probably was single last
like the the second talk I'm sorry Allie
but I have another meeting with now take
your time it's your birthday birthday
yeah yeah happy birthday thank you happy
back ok ok well thank you Thank You
Misha happy happy birthday makes me die
that's consistency coming from the
middle for this birthday yeah that's
great
yeah so thank you again is manager for
the day for the interview so I hope you
see you don't need to be a Titan called
a worker to be hiding not at all gah so
you need to be interested I want to want
to give something back to the community
and you can basically hope that kind of
motivate some of you to go and do that
and now we will welcome the second
speaker you I will just go to you and
present it it's okay with you I mean so
Ali is data scientists who work ideas
endangering personnel files and it will
present
of what he is doing for the UK industry
so is bad in London and yeah we're
really excited to see what he can we'll
talk about can you unmute yourself yes
yeah so hello everyone
thank you very much for having me and
Edwin it was really good deal thank you
very much
I really enjoyed the talk is Lemuria on
the quantum computing I think there's a
lot of potential in that space specially
if you looked like five to ten years
ahead in the machine learning space when
it comes to big data just to give a
background to myself before we go into
the presentation basically I'm a senior
data scientist now working for startup
tech startup in London called hack
partners and we build real tech products
and predictive or data analytics
solutions for the real clients real
companies and this specific talk that I
felt like I could share with you today
would be more related to NLP or natural
language processing and it would give
you a really good high-level
introduction to what NLP is all about so
if you've never done NLP before and you
want to get an introduction this talk
will be a bit mostly most of the
concepts high-level concepts as well as
I will show you a demo running like live
code so you can see at the same time
what those concepts translate into a
real-world application and this
application is currently deployed on
Azure services that is basically being
visualized on a client's dashboard to
help them with maintenance of their
assets so without further ado I'm just
going to show you my screen let me know
if you can see the screen all good
yes we can feel free all right perfect
so my background is actually mechanical
engineering so I did a traditional
degree in mechanical engineering and I
worked for a consultancy in London
within the rail sector mostly working in
data and operational modeling with like
- and data science tools such as pandas
or numpy on the side as well I worked on
digital railway signal processing so
digitizing the railway industry such as
the signalling systems become digital
and they use lots and lots of data
processing tools for this specific talk
the context is in natural language
processing so one of the biggest
problems that the UK railway industry
has is that they big they don't have
like a proper predictive or reactive
data database maintenance system for
maintaining their escalators and lifts
across the UK rail stations so currently
the way it works
people just call each other up and ask
about the assets and if an asset
requires maintenance they just basically
send someone to just maintain it and
instead of like using a data-driven
approach they just basically do more
like a scheduled approach where they
just schedule every month for - every
two months to just check up all the
assets and figure out if anyone any of
them are like requires maintenance or
replacing components and usually these
assets up like a lifetime of 25 years
and they just do it like every month or
something like that some assets more
some assets less and also if there's
like someone get trapped in the lifts or
in like an ask an escalator breaks down
they try to you like approach the
problem in a more reactive way so they
wanted to use data so you use like
sensor and data and maintenance reports
to basically figure out how they can
actually make this more make prediction
so that they don't spend a lot of time
and money on like maintaining these
assets
so the data I'm working - today is
mostly maintenance reports that are
populated by some of these maintenance
that they go inside and like they check
out the lifts and escalators and then
they sit down and then right they sit
down and write the text on the basically
device that then submits it to their
database and there is a lot of
maintenance report data there is at
least 250,000 reports like over the past
ten years so what they wanted to do one
of the things that they wanted to be
part of this dashboard was to have a
chart that shows what are the failure
types of all of these assets so repeat
the maintenance reports all of these
250,000 reports and tell me why that
acid fail was it like in the earth
leakage was it the oil of the hydraulic
ramp but broken was it like the door got
stuck was it the the lift got stuck like
what was the failure by reading the
maintenance reports and like these are
let's say texts that are about like at
least 5 to 10 sentences long each so if
you want to do it as a human it's just
not gonna be possible so that's where
that's where like NLP was really really
strong and that's how this project came
about like me charts you actually see if
we can use current data science
ecosystem libraries such as scikit-learn
NLT k-space see and so on to figure out
and pandas to figure out if we can
actually classify these maintenance
reports and as their failure types as
labels as the failure types so to give
you an idea what NLP is it stands for
natural language processing and it's an
interdisciplinary field between come to
science and linguistics we so it
basically allows computers to understand
human language so there are lots and
lots of applications there is a spam
detection sentiment analysis which is
basically reads a text and figures out
if it's positive or negative feeling for
the person who wrote it
it's about text generation
question-answering which usually ends up
like in like BOTS or conversational
interfaces
like Charcot's and so on this specific
example is about classifying documents
or classifying a bunch of sentences as
labels and there are multi multiple
labels there are at least two to twenty
or thirty labels we want to classify
these sentences by so the first idea
that comes into mind is using machine
learning so you know the data set is an
unlabeled data set and we want to label
it so what is the appropriate machine
learning approach here does anyone want
to answer you can try to type in the
chat if you want
so I will I will basically ask the
questions to make it more interactive
more fun so the the right approach the
right answer is that because it's on
unlabeled well the first thing we're
going to try let's try to basically
plaster use unsupervised machine
learning and cluster this these reports
you figure out what are their biggest
like words or clusters that pop up and
what are the themes and based on that we
don't go label them if if the clustering
algorithm works that's it that's that's
the problem solved we can just basically
get these reports pour it into
scikit-learn and then so I could say in
just cost there is it for us we just
have to assign a label to each of those
labeled numbers as like this is like
entrapment this is oil failure this is
like door failure that is like I don't
know like the gearbox is broken that and
like so on but make it easy go forward
so without further ado let's jump into
code so I could show you exactly what
the dataset looks like and so it makes
it more you know real-world so what i'm
doing here is i'm just basically
importing bunch of packages and to give
you a bit of context i'm just going to
go top to bottom and show you what all
these packages are so pandas is
straightforward we use it for data
analysis manipulation numpy as well if
we're going to do some manipulation with
you know numerical arrays and matrices
then we in quoting here bunch of
libraries that we can use as NLT cages
for natural language processing toolkit
that we use for processing text stacey
is a more advanced NOP library regular
expressions again it's to do with text
so we need that scikit-learn is for our
clustering algorithms so if you want to
do some clustering we're gonna use like
it then I'm pickling is just basically
to save some data
I'm also importing some stuff to do with
multi processing and Frank tools at some
point I will need to use parallel
processing so like put it on different
CPUs so they could run in parallel so
I'm importing these tools as well we
should make it to Python counter so that
I could count words and they were also
bunch of like other stuff
imported from ltk so these are like stop
words and some other functions that
allows me to do my job doing NLP and I
will go into all of these what these
things are from scikit-learn I'm
importing tf-idf vectorizing and k-means
I will go into those as well like what
they exactly what they do so these are
just basically I'm doing some initial
setup here basically initializing my
work let them intimate Isis and my stop
wait and stop words are basically they
refer to a word in the sentence that are
useless for doing any kind of machine
learning thing cut off or if and not
stuff like that so basically when you
take a sentence like this this is a
sample sentence you basically use stop
words to basically filter out all of
those things that is not very very
relevant so for example in this you
don't see off there because these are
the stop words so there is just this
list of words that are not very useful
they don't have they don't have any
value when you try to put your text into
an array and work with it if you if you
have worked with Python before all we're
doing in NLP is just basically working
with textual data and working with
shrinks so it's a lot of string
manipulation under the hood is nothing
like all of these libraries what what
they're doing is just doing a lot of
textual processing and manipulation
under the hood so it's not not anything
much important and I'm basically pod
doing here just basically setting my
maximum weight so I can show you some of
these texts in pandas so let's import
the library and let me show you how big
this library is this data set so it's
just taking some time to import the data
set I have defined the columns I want
where the data set is so it's lift an
escalator mass default data set and I'm
just basically defining some data types
for the columns that I need to work with
I'm also basically just a explicitly
changing some of these columns that
didn't actually go through properly
shows how to make sure it is working as
as I want it and then I'm gonna sample
just ten rows of data so there is
125,000 rows of text with five columns
here is it a sample of the data set so
nifty start observe is not responding
running cooling travel identified fault
qxt and pump so maybe there is an issue
with pump returned to side remove oil
from time blah blah blah blah out of
cell is already switched off again not
of service doors are not opening so this
is like an issue with the doors stuck
between floors again acid obstructed and
stock leaves stuck at bottom floor and
you can see it's like this it just goes
on on and on forever and it does have
some labels but these are very high
level it just basically says is it miss
use Mandal ism or wear until aborted
this they doesn't say anything like in
detail like what was it that was broken
was it like an obstruction was it like
someone got stuck in door inside like
what was it exactly that got broken that
so what we're trying to do is we try to
use NLP to assign labels to these rows
to show us exactly what are the
distribution of like you know various
types of failure so we can actually go
and assign a strategy to automate it so
that they could go and assign a strategy
to their maintenance strategy and one of
the things you would also notice is that
a lot of these are so please maintain is
actually have fat fingers so when they
write there's a lot of likes mistakes
and there's lots of like sneeze
spellings so that is another headache
that we need to sort out because when it
comes to working with like co2 tokenize
this data and like work with it it's
gonna cause issues if we have like a
bunch of me stop work me stop words they
they're they're gonna be exactly the
same words but because they've been
misspelled the computer doesn't
understand this so if thinks it's just
like separate new items that needs to
work and all I'm doing here is just
basically I define my own EDA function
so I could look into like each row and
like get various reports of like what
are the sample of each column
the distribution of them straight when
we look at their column type cross type
we can see that this this dataset is
hugely unbalanced there is lots and lots
of like rows of data that is to do with
wear and tear and a couple of them like
at least one fit as well is to do with
misuse vandalism unlike others like hot
weather storm damage flood damage and
all of those other things they are not
actually as much seen in them so our
challenge is to basically divide up
these three these four categories into
more categories with our labeling to
allow us to work with taste asset going
forward so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take a copy of my current data set
I'm not gonna touch the original and I'm
just going to work with the copy I'm
gonna get rid of all the line breaks so
I'm just basically replacing all the
line breaks with spaces by using regex
and then just taking a sample of data
the issue with this end is that when you
import this raw data in in Excel so
because this data set they open up in
Excel Excel reads the ends and has line
breaks and it shows them nicely
formatted but when you put it in in
pandas you have these like - and all
over the place and you cannot work with
it if you will be to pass that in it's
just gonna not really like it as such so
we getting rid of those and replacing
them in space so we can get really clean
just bunch of texts and they're the two
columns you're going to work with these
these two columns that I just
highlighted next we're gonna we're gonna
do the first thing we're gonna do so the
first thing we need to do is spell
checking there are a couple of
algorithms for spell checking and
depending on the algorithm you choose
your application will take either hours
and days and weeks and monster - your
spell check your document or it could
take a couple of minutes to spell to
check your document that's how far these
algorithms are like far apart within
each other so normally what these
algorithms do is they were it try like
in a native approach they take a
misspelled word and then just they look
into a dictionary using a
edit distance of how far like other BB
needs to check other words and if for
each word and so your data set is
125,000 rows of data each row has five
to six sentences and each sentence is
about 10 to 20 20 words do you know how
many words that it and it would take at
least one second
or one to ten seconds to check each word
using the net name approach so it would
take you ages even if you do it on like
multiple better pass parallel processing
so that's what the native approached us
with Peter Norvig
approach he plays around with the word
so it tries to delete some part of it
transposes cause of it replaces part of
the practice and insert parts in there
to figure out what to basically
magically land on a dictionary word that
matches that correctly spelled word if
that makes sense so it takes a
misspelled word and then plays around
with it to get to a matched word that is
in the diction or still with that one
you have to n to the 2 n plus a 1 is 1
like in terms of complexity of the
algorithm for it to run so it still is
not very fast and lastly we have the
symmetric spelling scene spell algorithm
that uses deletions and plays around
with that to get to the algorithms we
also instead of using transposes and
replaces and inserts it only uses the
mission's
to figure out what is the correctly
spelled word you'll be boss to the word
that we're trying to look at so if
you're just gonna run this I'm just
gonna show you what I mean by this this
algorithm working look at the escalator
so that's the word that this name is
spelled when I just run this algorithm
since spell on one row of data couple of
rows of data the escalator is not fixed
so if you're going to back this later on
if you're gonna talk you know it's all
of these texts into bag of words this
allows us to basically get rid of all
the invalid items and unclean data so
you just basically that's what we're
doing is try to clean the data yeah
next what I want to do is I want to show
you some tasks to do with multi credit
parts they're parallel processing so
here we showed that we managed to clean
the data for like five rows of data but
what happens in spell and see how fast
it is to run so we want to basically
calculate how long it's going to take
for us to clean the whole data set so
again remember is 125,000 rows so in
order to clean properly and that's what
we need to do so if I just run it on one
CPU it's gonna take me 467 milliseconds
what do you think it would take me if I
paralyze it into how many I have 16 CPU
cores
so this is 50 rows of data
feel free to post in the chat box less
so is it is it gonna take less one more
300 milliseconds so let me bring up my
CPU system so this is these are my CPUs
then they're not running as such let's
run it now so now all of my CPU cores
are running at maximum full speed trying
to process five rows of data
sorry 50 rows of data and spell checking
50 rows of data and let's see how long
it will take for it to process
so time it function is a magic function
that comes with Jupiter books it allows
you to basically time your code inside
Jupiter the way it works it uses
statistically it runs you a couple of
times so it runs it so for this one it
figures out how many times it needs to
round it and in each run it basically
loops through the code that many times
so this is running this code seven
months seven multiply one book so it's
seven times and it figures it out how
many times it needs to run that code in
order to figure out how long it would
take so it would basically to give you
an accurate estimate of how long your
code will take to run what I'm doing in
this one at this bottom with specifying
these parameters is I'm trying to get
exactly like tell it only to a 10 loop
with just one one otherwise it may go
crazy and then never ever ever ever
finish so while this is running what do
you notice so far that it this is
running so all of my CPU calls are
running at max speed
what is wrong here
so someone basically actually answered
the question already exactly where the
pool outside exactly so the lesson I
want to mention here is that look 15
seconds just 450 rules of data so
parallelizing is not always the answer
and when you don't need to actually use
it there is a cost to running
parallelization and the the apathy when
it comes to the spell checking algorithm
if you need to paralyze something what I
would suggest to do is to always go back
to the algorithm and figure out if there
is a better algorithm so I spent so much
time trying to spellcheck this dataset
only to figure out that actually the
algorithm I was using which was the
Peter Norvig algorithm and so there they
are library I was using was PI store
where that seen stuff it was taking ages
I took it on a parallel a paralyze
processing unit and I just went for
lunch I came back and he was still
running on 16 quarts and he wasn't doing
anything just because this symmetric
delete spelling algorithm is actually
1,000 times faster so you can see this
this code ran for seven runs and it took
15 seconds this one ran for seven runs
and it took only 400 milliseconds so
it's like orders of magnitude faster so
it's not always the best thing to
paralyze it what I wanted to show in
this one also I have the output open so
I don't need to run it this time I could
just show you the output of this second
a second one if I scroll down you can
see that actually for $2,000 of data
parallelizing actually did reduce the
time it would take to spellcheck this
data set so a spell check at least two
thousand rows of data so as soon as you
become bigger and bigger go into the
bigger date of data frames and bigger
data sets it does make sense to do
parallel eyes but again I would always
say go back to your go back to your
algorithms onto your codebase and
try to think if the parallelizing is
actually the right thing to do so that's
that's just basically what I wanted to
mention here next thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna do one of the things I wanted
I was most interested in was what are
the most common words in this data set
so if I if I want to do some clustering
what are the kind of labels that I would
need to play around with and I will need
to suggest when it comes to the mesh
building the machine learning or
clustering model so all I'm doing is
just looping over my data set tokenizing
it
and when I say tokenizing I mean just
basically taking a sentence taking baby
text and then dividing it into sentence
or taking a sentence and dividing it
into basically a bunch of words so this
is called the organization so tokenizing
it and then basically limit izing it and
checking if it's actually a word rather
than a number and if it's not in the
stop words so only include were words
that are actually words there are not
stop words and they are actually the
base word rather than rather than like
variations of the word so for example
variations could be clothes clothes
clothing so all of these the base word
is cloak yeah so that's that's what
limitation limit limit is Asian's does
so when I talk about limit ization
in stemming we just basically take the
base of the word in limit ization
basically you're taking all sorts of
variations of the word and then you just
basically replace them with one word so
when it comes to counting number of
words that have been done in your data
set so when it comes to an operation
called bagging which takes a piece of
text and then puts it into a counter
object and count how many times that
ayah that word has been you know I'm
being a period in the data set it
doesn't basically it's very clean and
it's very very there are no duplicates
in there so that's that's why I'm
limiting at the same time and that
that's what's happening here so I wanted
to identify the most common words in the
corpus which is here the
hundred seventy-three thousand mentions
of lift so this data set is mostly
talking about lifts that are out of
service under platforms and then there
are some escalators and then tours so
you can start to see like what are the
most common things that are happening in
this data set so when it comes to
building your machine learning model
what are the kind of words that you will
need to worry about when you're doing
that again so when I built this and it
doesn't provide me with much context
it's just basically a bunch of random
words other than vibe entrapment which
could be a good useful label to use
alarms and so on so I continue to be
doing something that is basically
building my own supervised machine
learning model so I think if I'm if I'm
right
Havering you're working on psychic land
right as the maintainer in this part you
would like this so I'm basically
importing something called a tf-idf
vectorizer from scikit-learn text
features module and what I'm trying to
do here is I'm trying to use the k-means
algorithm with a maximum iteration of
hundred and initializer of one with how
many clusters I am doing five clusters
eight clusters and twelve plus fifteen
clusters to train three models with
different number of clusters to figure
out what are the top five categories of
data categories or labels that these
models is trying to figure out so I'm
initializing my tf-idf vectorizer and
i'm going to talk to you exactly what
this tf-idf vectorize is doing so while
these are building the models so let me
run all of them so it's building three
models now what is doing building those
three models I'm training them let's go
back in here and talk about what tf-idf
is actually doing so tf-idf actually
what it does this is called Tam
frequency over in the inverse document
frequency so what it means is that it
counts how many times a word is
appearing in a document
it doesn't have hearing other documents
so for example if you have a document
about Albert Einstein words like
gravitational theory and relativity will
appear the most in that document but it
doesn't appear in a document that is
about Tesla and Nicola Nicola Tesla so
that document is heavily balanced
towards those words and it's about those
words this is similar to what like
Google does when it did when it comes to
do scos
and so like when it comes to your
website and your website is about some
specific keyword the tf-idf score of
your website is on that keyword and it's
just there it's just a nice feature
engineering approach for understanding
how each report is related to what label
so that's why I'm using tf-idf
vectorizer which is basically respect
arising at the same time and being a
calculating the tf-idf score which is
the axis bottom in order to build some
features that I could play it could use
in order to build their clustering
models so in order to figure out which
words correlate with each other and put
them into into clusters so if you look
at the first cluster so the five custom
model is built and it's there we have
used it too and yeah we are basically
not printing some of these clusters we
can see that the first cluster is about
lift platform service entrapments second
cluster is about stock level lift so
maybe the second cluster is about
talking about being stuck in a lift the
first cluster is about the camping
entrapped also the second is about
getting stock the first one is about
people getting entrapped the Fed is
about escalators tripping or
accidentally restarting basically I'm
not getting enough information from this
I'm not on so I trusted my data set it's
not giving me enough information to
basically go and build like will enable
these roads so apparently even if I use
different clusters different number of
clusters here I'm not I don't think
there is enough data in each report in
order to train a good model that would
allow me to label
these label these roads so even if I go
and predict on these on these roads and
I see like some of these have been
labeled zero one and two the ones is
about passengers getting sore that the
lifts getting stuck zero is a bad sign
of burning rubber lifts not working and
chair lifts on booking office side stock
so actually this is not doing a really
good job because these labels have
nothing to do with the ropes
they are like some bits that are not
exactly there again same as this one and
same as this one so what I try to do
here is I try to use unsupervised
machine learning and didn't work it's
just it's just not performing the way I
wanted to just because my data in each
row is not enough for me to build a
machine learning model on top of this
what do you think would be the best way
now going forward
so I'd have an unlabeled data set in
order to build any model on top I need
the I need to label it first
what would be the best way to go forward
you
we get from them guessing frequency
distribution of engrams
that could work what else can we do
so I did I didn't do the Ingram approach
I did more like a hardcore approach I
would say so I thought okay I have an
unsupervised machine learning problem
what if I try to make it semi-supervised
so what if I try to label some of these
label some of these rows of data myself
up to 20 or 30 labels and then if I can
label most of the data set then maybe I
could train head model on those data
sets in order for the model to then
label the rest of the data so doesn't
make sense so it is come to this called
the semi supervised machine learning so
that's what I started doing so first I
thought to myself okay first I start
checking didn't work properly we're just
gonna take ages for me to do what if I
try to insert up spell checking the
whole data set first I'm gonna back the
data set so I'm going to use bagging to
back my data set so if I look at the
backwards you're gonna see basically a
bunch of contour objects as well that
you just show you how many times each
word is appearing in each sentence then
instead of going and basically spell
checking all of the texts in each row I
just basically spell checked the bags
and if there is any duplicate back to
that spell check I wouldn't do it I
wouldn't spellcheck it anymore so it
just basically reduces the overload is I
did the computation on overload on on
the computer so it only spell checks
unique banks instead of like going and
spell checking the whole data set so
that's one of the things I try to do to
actually reduce the amount of
computational power and this is actually
now is backing some of these words so
I'm just gonna run some of these
functions so all these functions are
doing is just basically spell checking
the banks instead of spell checking the
the actual data set itself or all of it
concatenating all the texts together and
then spell checking them text and when I
do time it then he would it would allow
me to show you how each different
algorithm is working compared to the
each other so now the the bagging is
done so look at
Oh juice and Pollock columns on the
right hand side you would be able to see
what bagging does
so what bagging does is that it sees
this there is two words called Stannah
so there are standards the name of the
lift company is being appeared twice in
this piece of text so now with bagging I
have some kind of feature that I could
use to label these they label these copy
they label these rows in in a different
way compared to just using this on
supervised machine learning model
however I still do have some issues with
spells this spell checking some of the
words have basically incorrect spells so
what I need to do is I will need to
spellcheck all of the keys and then
basically combine their values so
combined accounts if those two keys when
I start check down and is corrected the
key and two keys are exactly the same it
needs to basically add up the count of
those two keys and basically to get rid
of one so that's what I'm doing with
these functions down here it's just I'm
basically combo is spell checking and
then basically combining them back up
just to show you how much difference
there is in to the algorithms so like
using the algorithm I'm just gonna
basically spell check one row of data
using Norwich algorithm and then I'm
gonna spell check one row of data using
the same spell so the Norwich algorithm
took two seconds using one loop so doing
seven runs it took two seven two seconds
to run the algorithm but we'd be
symmetric spell algorithm it took one
point six millisecond
he drowned for seven thousand loops he
drowned the seventh it ran basic it
basically ran at 7,000 times it only
took one point six milliseconds in each
time so this is orders of magnitude
difference in their spell checking
algorithm that abused just because I
basically use the correct algorithm
instead of like going and using a very
more naive approach so if every time
your application is like not doing
properly make sure that the algorithms
that are using all of the box actually
are performing really well compared to
other algorithms that are out there so
what do you see here what I've done here
so I have basically went into the data
set and it's just some hardcore EDA to
figure out what are the different types
of issues that have happened we didn't
within this text so I said to myself
okay I'm gonna come back my unsupervised
model on my unsupervised data set into a
labeled data set but instead of like try
to build and I said like figure out
using a frequency distribution of
engrams or anything like that I
basically just sat down and I wrote this
massive dictionary and I used a min
match so mean match key to categorize
these labels if there is too much of
these words then it's definitely door
failure so if there is a there is a word
that says door and then it's not like
not open or something like that there is
there is high chances door quickly and
then I basically use this dictionary to
label my data set it's a very very
simple hardcore approach so I don't
recommend it unless like you're on a
tight deadline or it's in some cases
it's more relevant compared to using
machine learning it's just basically
more easier to do so I'm just gonna show
you basically what it does so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna run this script
err on the data set in order to
understand how the rules of data is
actually now to be in Casa Christ so if
there are words in the banks that are to
do with alignment aligned or lined with
misalignment if there are words in the
backs do with overheating heating or
overheated that's doing overheating
power failure again to do with power
failure and so on so I didn't use a lot
of different labels just basically these
so that I could get like some idea on
how I can label my data set and if if I
can get this to work then I kind of have
solved the problem even if without using
machine learning so let's look at the
data here I yeah
will that be possible to finish in
around five minutes so that we get time
for some questions
yeah it is near the end perfect
great yeah good so then I ran this and
basically what I got is this one so you
have to label column on the right hand
side and then you have the text column
on the left hand side and I'm sampling
ten rows of data so immediately when you
see is that there is actually like the
labeling seems to be working if there is
something to do with noises so lift
doors are making strange noises so there
is an issue with excess signals flooding
platform five to eight subway water in
its sign flashing requires compound so
maybe there's an issue with flooding so
it does seem to be working to some
extent so we do need to do some kind of
analysis on this to figure out exactly
if it's done a good job at labeling the
data set but now if we look at some
statistics in because the Homer Hogg
with the labeling has done there are
only eight thousand rows of data that is
not labeled now so and these rows of
data when we look at them the text
itself doesn't say much about that road
it says please ignore a set of times an
engineer on site blah blah blah so there
isn't much information in this text
anyway for in order to help us
understand what this report relates to
like what is the issue with this left or
with this escalator even though when we
have backed it and we did it everything
else so apparently even though I did
hard code my dictionary to categorize my
rows of data it did it did work by me
just basically using bag of words and
doing all sort of like a standard data
cleaning features to do with text so if
I just look at the data this is what it
looks like so first thing I noticed when
I ran my data set is that actually I
think my dictionary is not very well
because I D I do have a massive
unbalanced table data set to do with
acid obstructed trip and jump and the
rest are like not as many instances of
that
in the data set so what I thought to
myself actually instead of having this
label dictionary on top I could break it
down into more labels and I could follow
the same process and break down the
labels even born in order to make my
labeling more refined and more detailed
so if I go ahead and do the same thing
and I show you how the label data set
which looks like it would allow us to
get an understanding of how many of a
sycamore means our descriptive
classifier is and it would also allow us
to go ahead in the future to build using
spacy which is an advanced natural
language processing library that allows
you to build neural networks and
programming to program neural networks
to train a model now on this data set to
figure out baby yepp to build a model
that would later on look at more reports
in the future and basically categorize
them in the right categories depending
on what the failure type of that asset
is so here now you see that after I
refined my dictionary I'm actually
getting much much better more balanced
still on balance but it's more to do
with the data itself than to do with the
the way I have defined my big my
categorization dictionary so it's doing
much better and I have like a good
balance of like a flogging misuse
excessive noise large failures and so on
and there's like 2,500 instances at
least of these ones so it would allow me
to Stephens enough label dataset to
convert my own supervised machine
learning model their machine learning
problem to a supervised machine learning
problem our semi supervised machine
learning problem so I when I tried the
model I could then go back and try and
try to label all of those rows of data
that have not been labeled before so
that is basically what I tried to do
going forward
however because because the more because
the application was meeting the
requirements to start to some extent and
this work has not done be done be done
but this could be something that could
be taken forward when it comes to for
example classifying various types of
failures when it comes to end
happens why are there some of the
reasons that people get entrapped in
UNIX and if those those type of labels
are inside the text to do with entra
prints then you can maybe use and train
model on top of that in order to go and
do this
so with outset this concludes the talk
and concludes the demo I'm happy to
answer any questions you guys have going
for what I'm to do with this ok we just
get a question from Evan is the data set
and balanced because of the type of
mashing breakdown because the type of
machines break down is unbalanced so the
lifts and escalators mostly get
obstructed and half-door failures just
because some components fail more than
the others so the high there is a higher
chance than the Doraville lift fails
because a lot of people use the doors so
the doors keep opening and closing so
statistically speaking if a door keeps
opening and closing there's a higher
chance that the door would break
compared to the vapir box or the power
so the data set is unbalanced because
it's a real-world data set so because of
the real because in a real world the
failures are unbalanced
yes Nathan I got another question from
you like guessing did you come figure
the company that are using topic another
so that could have been something that I
could try yes
so there are on different approaches
that you can take one was someone
mention frequency of distribution of
engrams the other one could have been to
do topic model and figure out like that
relationships between different topics
and these labels so that those are those
are areas that could be investigated
further yes but I had at that immediate
time because this was under the deadline
and we were trying to just produce
something that we could put on the cloud
to categorize these failures we
basically sticked with just a simple
solution of dictionary that uses the
second mean match key to identify what
category needs to categorize each for
each row
what I love about using name and
evolution for labor in again the same
thing so named interesting recognition
for labeling depends on the text so it's
usually more useful when you have like
text but I would say it has people in it
it has like dates and things like that
I've had like when it comes to only
named entity recognition I don't think
in this data set or at least in the text
because the text is so specialized it
wouldn't give the named entity
recognizes enough to work with in terms
of features that would allow you to
build something like a glutton machine
learning model on top to normally those
those recognized people or dates or like
locations or things like that these
states are just talking about like
objects or assets or things like that in
the data yeah cool thank you any other
question I I have one so this being
deployed and it's currently you I'm
sorry I'm hearing a question
so is it deployed this is deep no idea
and will that any plans to do will be
are you still working on it and
improving it yeah so the plan is to
develop this further when it comes to
the second phase of the project so one
of the things this doesn't get provide
is that it so whenever you see like the
number of entrapments we have in deaths
there are at least five about 5500 or
6,000 entrapments this we don't know why
these entrapments are the case and we
want to know that further so when it
comes to bloating a more accurate model
or a more accurate way of doing the
you will need to build a more accurate
solution and then that accurate solution
will then be reapplied to this as well
so that you get more accurate labels and
you also get less less I would say
unbalances in the data set if those
imbalances is issued by your approach
also correlated with your question
ladies and that so what have been the
feedback you did by it
oh so this has been recently deployed so
I was to basically waiting for the data
to come in and see how the data is being
automated automatically labeled when it
comes to the labeling it's being
deployed I think two months ago okay
yeah okay any other question we still
get quite good coming from that guessing
great to see real world application of
NLP very cool really really cool to see
basically real-time working yeah it says
if you read B oh it's for in real life
yeah I get a question from Chris Young
do you see as an option two are separate
models a label or label set and then
accept some results with some threshold
my acceptance rate so that is a good
idea so you could actually train for
each label you could basically train
separate models that would be very
specialized on that table and what that
would entail
is that like for labels that have a lot
of data such as asset obstructed and or
failures that models will then become
really sensitive to if exactly these add
or failure it would label it as door
failure so these are actually ways you
can go and improve this approach which
is like a very simple distinction
approach into a more robust model-based
approach where you have like it
considers all sorts of noise in the data
and figures out that actually depend
it's just not seen the words ended in
this text but actually there are some
relationships between these words that
make that report related to do Australia
so that is a good option and that is
something that could be worked on going
forward another thing I want to mention
is that this data set is unbalanced from
light failure onwards so light failure
to ethnic age there is not much data to
work with what you could do is you could
do something called synthetic minority
or a sampling technique or smutty and
what smooth it does is that it generates
synthetic data by interpolating between
data points so you generate text by
interpolating by learning some of the
patterns of the current samples that are
under sampled and basically trying to
increase the increase the training data
set in such extent that that the labels
are balanced now even though the data
set is unbalanced by nature the data set
will become balanced just by you doing
some kind of synthetic minority over
sampling technique on top so that is
something that could be is something
that could be looked into to see how we
can actually reduce the impalas such as
so that the models we train or have more
training data and if if we want to go
with one model that one model becomes
more generalized compared to using
sixteen models or twenty-five dollars or
how many models there are the problem
with models is that you will need to
deploy them and then you will need to
predict it send requests to do them and
in having one model will give you less
cost under cloud infrastructure compared
to having sixteen models so it's not
just about building the most accurate
application it's also about costs so if
you can build a generalized model that
can perform well on all labels it's way
better compared to having sixteen super
specialized models do you do you happen
to also have checked the imbalance layer
and checking the library maintained by
maintenance it's called imbalance in
balance a imbalanced learn as in line
balancing and no no I haven't seen a boy
dies interesting we have some good tools
so it does over sampling and under
sampling and in sample
oh this is good as well so they are like
lots of different ways so it does have
smoothie but this is kind of it would
look like so the yellows you can see she
knows and usually yellow dots and the
purple dots are not a lot and basically
it's doing some crime interpolation to
increase the green and yellow dots to
some extent and then there are some
purple in there but it's increasing
daily Purple's a lot and by interplay
basically interpolating between
dimensions of data okay
tink welcome so ready thank you very
much thank you very much
cluck-cluck-cluck
so you will be able to share the slide
[Music]
but the code for some reason for some
company reason you want to be able to
show so in the standard thank you very
much to ferry to share everything with
us yeah well I will try to see if I can
share the code as well so I will ask and
then if it's possible I try to share the
code - yeah right okay also thanks
everybody for joining the the Demeter
even zoom on YouTube
we will be now I'm gonna stop
broadcasting on YouTube but well we may
continue hanging out like this
just a reminder so the reason next week
[Music]
check it out for food building yes I ate
General Conference in November and they
call proposal and focus so